Today,
I'll be speaking with doctor Jo Anne
Bakar Roski professor of psychology at
Vanderbilt University where she
directs the Vocal Acoustics Laboratory.
Her work there focuses on laughter and
other domains of vocal communication
including the vocal expression of emotion,
infant directed baby talk as well
as speech acoustics more generally.
Um, she's previously served as an
associate editor for the journal,
cognition and emotion and has
received several awards for her work,
including grants from the NSF
as well as the an IMH. Her work,
not surprisingly on laughter,
has been widely discussed in the media,
including the BBC La Times,
Scientific American and discovery.
Um, just as a mere example.
So with this work on laughter,
I'm excited to now turn to our experts
in emotion interview with doctor Jo Anne
Bakar Roski from Vanderbilt
University on laughter.
So welcome Joanne. Thanks for speaking
with us today and thanks for having me.
I'm excited about this.
I'm excited to. Um,
so I wanted to start by asking you a
little bit about what first got you
interested in studying emotion.
I actually stumbled on it by accident.
I was studying in post with behavior
and I was looking for some sort of
physiological correlate that would go
along with the state of being impulsive.
And a colleague suggested that I record
people's voices and that turned into
vocal expression of emotion and
I really got interested in voice.
And what came along with that was
understanding emotions as well.
So it was a good accident. I mean gotta
love serendipitous accidents, right?
Yes. So I wanted to then
ask you about your work.
So I mean it's really exciting
and you're widely known,
especially for your influential work on
the acoustics of laughter and if we've
even developed a comprehensive
laughter dictionary.
And I'm wondering if you could tell
us a little bit about some of the most
exciting discoveries here.
I know all of us are really curious about
what is laughter and can there really
be different kinds of laughter.
I think it's one of the most
fascinating behaviors that we engage in.
And I think one of the surprising things
to learn is how readily people laugh.
And so we can bring people into the lab
and have them do pretty much anything.
And as long as they are in pairs
of people or groups of people,
then they'll laugh a lot.
So that was really surprising to me.
Another surprise was just how rich
laughter is as a behavioral repertoire.
And so,
well as listeners we can categorize these
all is kind of falling in a laugh lump
of sounds.
There are surprising acoustic very
variations in the sounds and the acoustics
themselves or just markedly different
than we see in typical speech.
And so we have things like the pitch of
laughter goes wildly all over the place.
We also sometimes produce what are
called acoustic nonlinear charities,
which are very unusual in
normal voice or normal speech.
And we see them in laughter a
good proportion of the time.
So that's been really exciting.
And then another thing that interests
me is the occasions when we don't laugh.
Like what is it about our social partner
that would lead us to not laugh or even
inhibit our laughter.
Wow.
So can I ask you a question then about
this? So in what ways would you say are,
you know,
sort of not all laughs alike?
I think that one of the most important
distinctions is whether laughs or voiced
or not.
So we kind of lump laughs into these
voiced and unvoiced categories.
And what it means to be a voice,
to have a voice blast is that the vocal
folds are important in the production of
that sound.
And so when we produce a voice sound,
it has a periodicity to it because the
vocal folds are operating in synchrony
with each other.
When we produce an unvoiced sounds,
either the vocal folds
aren't involved with,
they're involved more chaotically
and unvoiced sounds are noisier,
they're more turbulent.
And so things like grunts and snorts
are often very rich vocabulary.
Reid Branson snorts are often unvoiced
and we'll snorts or necessarily envoys
cause they're coming through the nose.
And um, and voice sounds of what we,
I think of as prototypical laugh sound.
So we think about these kind of
song like qualities to laughter.
Those are voiced laughs.
And what we've learned about those laughs
is that they are much more likely to
elicit positive emotion in
the people who hear them.
So listeners to hear voice laugh,
say they're sexier than unvoiced laughs
that they're more likely to want to meet
the person who produced the laugh.
They think it's better for a laugh track
and they're saying it makes them feel a
lot better than unvoiced sounds or
unvoiced laughs and unvoiced lasts can
actually elicit negative
emotions in people.
So kind of begs the question of
why we produce so many of those,
but we do their prior
to hire our repertoire.
So speaking of that,
I mean you've alluded to some important
individual differences and laughter
profiles and I wonder if you could say
a little bit about some of the really
fascinating gender differences that
you've found here when examining these
different acoustic laughter profiles.
I think the gender differences are just,
they're fascinating. So yeah, one thing,
we don't get the standard.
I think people expect that women laugh
more than men and we've never seen that.
So we've now conducted boy at least a
half dozen behavioral studies with a
substantial number of
people in each study.
And we've never found that women
laugh overall more than men do.
But it really depends on who our social
partners are that drive laughter.
So for example, people laugh
more, and this isn't surprising,
but we find that people laugh more when
they're with somebody than when they're
alone. And then they also laughed more
with friends and if they're paired with a
stranger. But the most interesting
finding with these, um,
sex differences is that what
male subjects do I think?
And that is that when males or with a
friend, especially with a male friend,
they laughed more and they
produce higher pitch laughs,
they produce longer laughs and it's,
they're these kind of over the top laughs
that I think that we expected ahead of
time that women would actually
do with their women friends.
But it's actually the guys who were doing
it with their guy friends and they'll
do it with female friends as well.
And they will rarely produce these
laughs when there was a stranger.
And that all gets it notions about what
kinds of sounds do you want to produce
with someone who you know
versus who you don't know.
So she think about males.
Um,
they can actually work to kind of
reinforce an ongoing relationship.
If they produce these voice lasts
that make other people feel good,
but that might be too much acoustic
information if the mail hasn't met the,
the stranger male with a
stranger, females. So if you
can imagine it as a female,
if you were to be at a party and a male
who you've never met before came up and
just laughed really loud and long
and I pitched, you'd be like, Whoa,
that's too much information. It's kind
of like, you know, too much overload.
It is overload.
It's too much.
I'd like too much eye gaze
of too much physical contact.
So males don't produce those
kinds of laughs with a stranger,
but they produce them a lot
when they're with a friend,
especially with their guy friends.
Interesting. I mean,
speaking of friendships,
I know you've also looked at this really
intricate kind of temporal dynamics of
laughter and the ways that it
can differentiate, you know,
close friends from just acquaintances.
I wonder if you could say
something about that too.
Yeah. We looked at, um, what
we call the intifada laughter,
which essentially just
means back and forth.
Laughter and friends are much more likely
to produce laughs within like a second
or two of their other,
the friend that they're being tested with.
We're strangers or just
discoordinate in their laughter.
It's almost like a random event.
Um,
what's even more interesting is that
the friends are more likely to have this
antipasto or synchronous
laughter for voice laughter.
So the idea is that if voice laughter
makes other people feel good,
the idea with friends is that they can
have a learned emotional response to the
laugh acoustics of the
friend who they know.
So they've been with
this person repeatedly,
they've shared a lot of good times
together. They say their friends.
And so when one person produces
this voice laugh sound, yeah,
the person has this very quick,
rapid kind of learned response that
includes laughter and in response to the
initial friend laughing.
So interesting. You know,
social relationships.
I mean you've also uncovered these really,
really,
I think just like groundbreaking
insights into sort of the distinct social
consequences of different laughter
types that you've spoken about today.
And I wondered if you could
say a little bit more about,
in what ways do these voice versus
unvoiced laughter elicit different social
responses from other people?
I think, um, I don't want to correct
your question, but I want, go ahead.
We actually haven't studied directly
social consequences and I think that is a
really key question and it's one that
we're like directly underway starting to
Estin lab. So it's really exciting and
I think that's critically important.
What we've done is studied laughter
in an almost disembodied way.
So people come to the lab,
they're in a perception study essentially
they come into a sterile environment
and they hear these labs over headsets,
but they're not interacting with the
person when they're making judgments about
the laughs. And if tested
people in the social situations,
we haven't yet analyzed data that we have.
On what,
how much did you like your partner if
they were producing lots of voice laughter
versus how much did you like your partner?
They weren't producing those sounds
that they weren't laughing a lot.
And so we're just really at the beginning
stages of being able to address that.
But I think it's really the most important
kind of question we can be asking
about the sounds,
well I can't wait to hear what your
findings, you know, on earth. I mean,
do you think in any way some
of these findings, I know some,
it sounds like it's at the forefront
of where you're working right now,
but I wonder if you know, where at any
point to have a sense of, you know,
how we ought to laugh, you know,
in society and social interactions.
I think the results have
implications for that. But the, um,
I don't think we have a lot
of control over our laughter.
So when we try to shape it,
it's actually a challenge.
And if we want to really
shape it for our lifetime,
we really have to kind of work at that.
So we might have to work at making her
laugh less loud or making sure to laugh.
So whatever. I think we do though
to the course of development,
learn a whole lot about what kinds
of sounds work in what circumstances.
Um, I think that the same way we learn
things like I mentioned earlier about eye
gaze and, and physical proximity.
We learn what works in,
in with different kinds of people
and different kinds of circumstances.
And I think we do the
same for our laughter.
And then I think that we
actually run into pretty, um,
I don't want to say dramatic,
but I think people really can have social
difficulties when they use laughter in
the wrong way or in the wrong
sorts of circumstances. Um,
and so people talk anecdotally about
that and we haven't directly studied that
either at this point.
But I do think that in the absence
of using laughter effectively,
people really can have challenges
in their social relationships.
So when you say that about sort of
where your path is taking you, you know,
into the world of emotion,
kind of serendipitously
and now becoming, you know,
the laughter expert,
you know,
and all the discoveries you've made
in the directions you're going.
Where do you see, looking ahead,
sort of the future of emotion headed?
What are the important directions?
I think,
um,
well actually I was reminded of this all
today when the New York Times announced
that Obama was about to spend many,
many millions of dollars to understand
the brain. And I thought, well,
surely there'll be an important role
for emotions and psychology in this.
And I think that,
you know,
on the one hand we are traveling
and understanding the brain more,
but I think it's also important to kind
of hang on to behavior and that really
what's most important down the road is
to make links between brain behavior
relations and a more naturalistic way
then we've done with some of our lab
paradigms to date.
Um,
and I think another thing that's really
exciting coming down the road with
emotions we search is being able to
use behavioral genetics techniques to
understand, especially disturbances
and dysfunctions in laughter.
And they really see the next 10 years
is exploding in both of those frontiers.
Okay.
So my last question for you then is what
advice do you typically give students
who come to you and ask,
you know,
your thoughts on should I embark in this
field and what are important? You know,
ways that I should be thinking about
becoming an emotion researcher.
I think, um, what I see
with a lot of students is,
is a really get revved up about emotions,
which is great.
Um,
and if they get caught up in technique
a little bit too much and or tools.
And so they want to learn imaging or
they want to learn eye tracking and they
want to learn psychophysiology.
And so what I try to shape students to
really understand is that those tools and
techniques are always going to be
there. So behavioral genetics, right?
It's going to be the next of,
of those tools that we can use.
But the most important thing they can do
is to identify some core questions that
they're passionate about that really tell
us something about the heart of what's
going on with emotional processing.
And if they can get, you know,
just develop those important questions
and follow through, then then yes,
they can learn imaging and yes,
they can learn all these things,
but the questions themselves
are the most important.
Well, thank you so much for
speaking today. It's been
such a pleasure. Thank you.
So this concludes our experts and emotion
interview with Dr Joann background ski
from Vanderbilt University.
Thanks again.